all right what's your name Croton beard
or Carson Pirie
exhale boiler Fresno California but uh I
moved to Houston Texas when I was two so
as well as raised it well
well I've been in skid row since 2013
well actually on actually 2006 I came
from I came from using Texas to
Sacramento to see my mom and my mama and
and my two younger brothers moved from
Texas to Sacramento in 89 and I didn't
see my mom no more to 2006 so I wouldn't
see my mom so you know so I came to
Sacramento and you know and after I
stopped in Sacramento for a while and
you know I've been through Reno in and
you know Landon phileo and opening stuff
I want to I want to see Hollywood once
the other woods so I saw it as some
questions about her about LA and
everybody everybody I've talked to in
Sacramento
do you like we don't go to LA we don't
go to LA but for what
and so I just wanted to see it and you
know so I came
and it was a I had already had a drill
problem when I came you know so it you
know he got a was my control
it's paw Patrol you know I end up in
prison and I'm in prison but I had
already done time before in Texas and
California prison is is is nothing is it
nothing like Texas I'm saying is so
sorry will
well well California prison you
understood about your own two feet as a
man if if the people from you in your
city or from your neighborhood see it
you you know you're still in your to
visa man you know then then they're back
here then they're back you give to
someone it was a major altercations you
know California prison is it is a lot
different man it's like uh it's like say
like a ruffle if I thought if I from
Long Beach got from Long Beach
California you know you know they know
I'm in California you know I do
something does she I should have done it
can started write it you know it doesn't
need indeed of actually actually have I
mean know I've been snorting heroin off
announced up in 15 years old
yeah the only reason I never stuck the
needle almost got scared of needles so
it always been too fuzzy bubble and the
first time I did it yeah yeah I'm not no
saint for to my first somebody mmm this
is like the best feeling in the world
and you know
if you get really every other heroine X
the same thing will well I own I do the
Ossining I mean I mean I made up I might
know I might know somebody they need
something and I played a middleman and
I'll make sure everybody everybody
satisfied here buddies
everybody just involved in in his little
business arrangement everybody satisfied
I just make sure everybody is fair here
but it's fair you know because they
agreed to eat and all type of and do you
know well I would say I will blow and
say pretty much have a pill I will
participate
I'm a participant I'm a ho
you know pips House vote as yourselves
it sounds like it sounds like it sounded
like somebody street name sugar nuts you
know yeah yeah and a person who's
providing a service by the service in in
you know he's keeping it honest he's
keeping it he's cheating respectable
yeah and and and you have you have
longevity and before ever you doing yeah
yeah
truly many money as usual evil man
money money money says money says so far
on to us it says so far yes man I'm
saying I fired that wouldn't necessarily
be there if he was broke if he was broke
and so I don't know but I actually think
that I'm just as much addicted to
hustling and the lifestyle because that
come along waiting man that come along
with it you know
but first my uncle's fries
he takes it to me my uncle not ahead by
three friends you know you know the Owls
hammerheads you know if you're not
Indian even I did feel go they go pull
up they go pull a nice rubber you know
so uh what his friends came over to him
he came over to my house he came to my
house
again with the miles and you know I
never figured he had it he had a big
Mercury Marquis and this mother friend
and he said me think we tried to call so
I said man huh I said memory drops up at
12 years old man you know my grandfather
had his own business that usually takes
for 54 years man he had three of brick
houses built for honor you know he did
all this by selling dirt was he
pi
yeah it's alone
yeah he is we came in didn't get a drop
it so you see he says he you know he's
he keyed up good on now he's even I know
yeah that's severe cue that you're off
yeah I have $2.00 man and it's like it's
like it's like the joy of my life I mean
it's like um my youngest daughter named
Jessica she she graduated from
University of Texas in Austin you know
she's a she's a coach now you know yeah
yeah
yeah to daughter Simone yelling youngest
daughter named Jessica last year every
her statistics and more to totally
Brandi she gradually got away for t
issue ticks of the University of Houston
taste from so yeah so on yeah man I'm I
think the Lord did I had two dollars
instead of two sons man because my two
sons man he'll probably be in the CH
dota of course of course a difference
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
and in that its sole head of so and
straight to the table man
I got a testimony man that is someone
I'm seeing I'm saying if if you wouldn't
be even
you know so sorry
Weber's losing this question oh well he
might blow from you a man
God got a job for me to do he got job me
to do and yeah um yeah man in in our own
yeah man is just I'm um I'm really
really I'm really been truly to to stop
get half
all right good luck with everything
thank you